[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys it is
still currently ladies night as you can
see here
oh yes it's ladies night it's too much
traffic special guest today actually we
have three special guests today a lot of
special guests i'm not really special
hey hey y'all leader of the king just
leader baby
yeah what's up with your last name dawg
really are you know
on your last name hey what's up hey the
ones i know
aka it's pretty much it's a it means
spanish for like dung beetle but in
spanish slang it means the n-word
oh how did that how well you okay this
is what that means is that the dung
beetle stance yeah dung beetle how did
dung beetle become your filipino last
name or the enemy i don't know
yeah
that's true what about the latter i
remember when i first read his last name
i was like i'm gonna just say my yate
that's that's how people say it because
i think it's me
that's the proper way the proper way is
which is this is what i just said right
but sometimes like i say like
depending where i am so have you ever
found somebody by saying your own name
no but it's funny because i never caught
it no a lot of people have caught it
okay when i was in spanish class my
spanish teacher was like chad
mayate and then all the spanish kids are
like all laughs like oh [ __ ] it's tight
but are there any dung beetles out there
yeah
why is everybody laughing does that
laugh you know if it's a common spanish
last name or do you think a conquistador
was [ __ ] around to be like we're
going to call this one mayate and that's
like a great great great grandfather
we're [ __ ] around in general yes
and your great great great great grandpa
was like i'm a mayate now that's how we
ended up with names like that and you're
last i'm ryan pendejo ryan pendejo
that's crazy
[Laughter]
when when the spanish were driven out
they hid all their inside jokes in our
names
yes
so how did you become the leader of
kenji's oh easy so
[Laughter]
two-step process two-step function
are you a higher-up because i know you
guys have a hierarchy system where the
quest is like more democratic this guy's
serious with a watermelon it's [ __ ]
about this stuff
i wouldn't say democrats you guys got
like a chain of command in there yeah
i'm b team baby what's that big team b
like on the bench but then you pull you
in sixth amount of the year is that true
i heard uh kendra's membership
i heard kendra's membership
no deny any allegations here all right
i'll need to ask mike
they also beat their members so
a little bit yeah i'll tell you what you
ain't see team am i right yeah you write
as [ __ ] see
oh no
you set yourself up for that one who's
the ct yeah who's on stage
josh ventura
we have a round table yeah everybody
sees each other equally and stuff like
king arthur in the [ __ ] knights of
the round worries this round
yes would you consider yourself so when
they asked chad mayante from and would
you be like uh poreiotics or would you
be like uh kenja's or would you be like
something else you know like what
philippines the philippines yeah
from the philippines
what would be your thing oh honestly
periodics right right i thought so
i do say i say oh have you seen like
americans with dance crew and end up
like yeah i'll be like periodics if
that's a kid's voice they have
definitely not seen it exactly yeah i
say
i say periodics first because that came
first
funniest thing is so i was hanging out
with josh so you guys know who josh is
uh actor also dancer very good at the
robot all those [ __ ] right
josh cracks me up so we're out we're out
in south pasadena and there's this
little girl running a kindred shirt
right josh is a kid just but josh looks
like a homeless person right so josh
comes up goes to the goal your kitchen
she goes ew
and i was like yo she doesn't know
you're in the group she's like you're a
homeless guy
see if i can eat him she was so [ __ ]
funny
you can see like his heart shattered
like hey man i danced too [ __ ]
and he doesn't look like he could dance
at all
until you
he looks like a substitute teacher yeah
everybody [ __ ] loves it but those are
the ones that smoke it the first first
time i ever saw him dance um i think
we're like shooting the skit or
something and then he was making fun of
someone doing the robot and i'm like how
come you're making fun looks so [ __ ]
good what the [ __ ]
and then he just started getting into it
and i'm like what the [ __ ] this guy good
dad it's like a [ __ ] what they
look like you know what's crazy yeah
one one of his strongest dance styles is
atl crank because he's
[ __ ]
from
atlanta
mean as in like literally this fool
knows how to shake his booty
like a like for real for real like
training
another word what was that start with
the b
right a [ __ ] i don't know yeah
[Laughter]
like
crazy what about you you got any cool
josh stories
we're not asking about it we're like
we're talking about other kids it's like
i do not other than the first time i did
see him dance was yes he was doing the
[ __ ] booty shake oh itself that's
very true does that crank how did you
end up in kendra's after being in
periodics already like uh i don't know
easy we won and then anthony was like we
need winners on the team so he got me on
oh
what a recruiter how do you feel about
just [ __ ] stealing members from other
desperate people dude you can't beat
them have them join you
good answer dude how's the quote right
hey you want to join us
how'd you steal mike's song from cava
modern den
i know everything
all of his lifelong friends kid just
first but as a former gang member i have
to say that when i was i was doing
youtube and dressing up as uh fake
vietnamese uncles i was super judgmental
toward these dancers because i was like
how the [ __ ] are these hood hopping
[ __ ] jumping ship from their family i
was like these guys are so [ __ ] up
especially because i live with ken i
know the [ __ ] periodic drama all that
[ __ ] and i'm all like all you guys
family never breaks up [ __ ] you guys i
can't believe you're my friends but what
if the dad leaves dude
like what my dad did no like one of my
[Laughter]
the dad leaves then the family's not a
family
well the dad left
but still man you got to continue the
spirit it's like the [ __ ] what's his
name jon snow his dad died right but
what did they won but do they do they
end the whole winterfell crew nah nah
right they bring it on right so they're
bringing it up
[Applause]
no no you don't do that
did you feel like you lost a father
figure in periodic so it happened no
hell no all of the brothers came
together or sisters
there was never an issue with with some
of periodics going to changes no one was
left out at all
i mean other than people not making it
onto kinships
that's some real real
you're like not good enough yeah how do
you pick who who you absorb he's the
guest ask him then i'm gonna ask you you
you know the more motivation
i told ken not to do that because i said
you know when you join a [ __ ] gang
the proper way to leave that [ __ ] is to
get jumped out so i was like ken if your
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] decides to join
kenji's you're out of my house that's
what i told him you actually told him
that you don't even have a house
at the time he was living in my house
that he paid rent in
[Laughter]
i think we are just not good at getting
advice
because
we have dancers asking comedians for
life advice and then we got dancers
hosting a comedy show
everything's just [ __ ] up i mean this
is how i looked at it was that like
uh as a dance team we were all together
and that was like our nba team and then
like ken jones was like the all-star
team and they were picking from
different crews so they're the global
harlem globetrotters
who's the wnba team oh wow
i'm honored come on
you guys wear wigs on the show come on
we wear wigs off the show joey didn't
let me join the all-star team he did it
was called jk
um
okay
can
he's not here right now he's editing the
videos
i have a good question for dancers do
you guys joints [ __ ] hurt like crazy
i bet this guy does because you guys are
very easy
for somebody like you very dynamic and
you just like to break your kneecaps you
used to do it man
i think it's just like you got extra
elbows they're not egg well not anymore
don't you have like calcium in it or
something i did yeah it like if i just
like it it'll just like blow up and then
for like two days it'll just slowly go
down and then you're balding up here
aren't you tommy a little bit yeah but i
think that might just be genetic
all right so do you still feel stuck
here like barely spins and then you
gotta get the hairpiece like what
happened you can always tell which which
guys do head spins too much is because
they're like prematurely like you know
but then you'll see also a little lump
yeah wow i don't have the lump that's
why i think oh i'm probably just
thinning normally is that why you have
the crazy hair to make up for all the
[ __ ] lumps in your heads
to hide it no because you don't do it
[Laughter]
his
this happens from all the moves i did it
just went this way you don't spin that
much no
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you do not feel such as stress pain
anxiety and anxiety is exactly what i've
been dealing with these days it's been
crazy so i quit coffee it's been about
90 days plus
it's been it's been pretty nuts and this
is all caffeine products no soda nothing
no energy drinks right and so i've been
sleeping like a freaking baby but
sometimes i wake up in the middle of the
night especially the first week when i
was quitting caffeine it was freaking
nuts i'm having straight up adrenaline
anxiety panic attacks i'm just like what
the hell is there a hyena behind me i
don't know what the hell to do right
hyena
i felt like a mountain lion was chasing
me well you know yeah and then i was
just scared as hell so i got up and i'm
like oh i'm awake but now i can't go
back to sleep and you need your sleep
and i need my sleep so i created an
unwinding kind of routine for myself i
take a couple of drops of fields put it
on my tongue and then i go off into a
different room and just meditate
and then come back and i feel much more
chill and i'm ready to go back to sleep
i sleep for a couple hours wake up and
i'm ready to start today and it kind of
blew my mind but it helped me in my
process
and basically what's cool is that cbd is
not harmful and it's pretty easy to use
i just use a couple of drops on my
tongue and it goes wham
it's really cool because it helps with
stress sleeplessness anxiety and pain
even and if you don't know how much to
take they even have a customer hotline
so you can call them and they'll walk
you through the whole process so start
feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com off
the record and you'll get 50 off your
first order with free shipping that's f
e a l s dot com off the record to become
a member and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping fields.com off the
record it's a price you pay like if you
look at rainan from jabba like he has
the little head spin thing too oh it's
like a little top yeah
what's the dancer's equivalent of being
jumped out of the gang
jumped i don't know we've never jumped
to anybody else you freely let people
come in and out like we don't ask these
guys
true b-boy crews are a little more
severe about that [ __ ] yeah dude that is
so wrong
no not at all questions is not even at
all of you which is like is this barely
a dance crew why did you guys increase
just a bunch of dudes that's it
so why did you guys decide to become a
protein bar brand
a pro wow
protein that's funny because we actually
did get into it with them a little bit
with quest nutrition
really tell me the details because
because at some [ __ ] random point
like we were like oh that's funny
there's a [ __ ] protein bar with the
same name we didn't think it'd be a
problem somewhere down the line after a
couple years they sent like an email
blast going hey everyone like joined the
new quest crew and we were like the [ __ ]
straight up and we got the email too and
it was like be part of the quest dance
crew they're making a crew they have one
that dances at all the fitness yeah and
they were calling it the quest crew so
stupid and sending us notices to join it
we were like you know who we are kidding
yeah we were like oh okay this is why we
trademarked it in the very beginning
actually own the trademark they can't do
that but nothing happened really so they
still did it no they didn't they didn't
still do it they what they did was they
had us come over to the headquarters to
just like talk about it give you some
free bra yeah you met you meant tom
bailey they just i don't think so they
just gave us a bunch of free [ __ ] and
they were like we're gonna change the
name it won't be called quest crew they
just call it the q crew or some [ __ ]
they hit some quest bars
they all just look like ben stiller and
dodge ball and [ __ ]
this is lasers
so the quest studio that you guys got
the name from didn't have the trademark
not for a dance crew yeah we only owned
it for dance crew that's it yeah so we
were like dude that's the one thing you
can't do and someone did it it's like
weird so bluntly too like and they
invited you over which is hilarious
all right i guess it's very civil yeah
yeah
who's the worst dancer in [ __ ]
kenji's yeah
[Laughter]
just look at that right who's the worst
dancer
you want to know like our perspective
who's the worst dancer you can yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we don't know anything everybody's
amazing i don't even think i've seen all
40 of you guys dead i don't know
like all the members whoever
how do you split that much money
that's not how it works but
shut the [ __ ] up
let's stick the business out of this
but for us who's the worst dancer yeah
who is it yeah go ahead chad
yeah i know and the guest is asking you
the question
spicy chad i only know the best ones i
don't even know i don't know one of the
best ones who was the worst
the best out of the best out of mike and
anthony
imagine
just save yourself and save me
shut up dude no i wouldn't say you're a
goatee bastard everybody knows you're
the best one like we [ __ ]
say that all that that hurts even more
now
are you trying today's the best one i
think anthony's probably the best brain
on kenjus that's brave damn that's
pretty bad then dude so you would beat
everyone in a battle you beat everyone
in the battle [ __ ] no [ __ ] fafsa form
fill-outs yeah
a financial aid smart dude
[ __ ] fast i've heard that we're in so
long
i appreciate that who do you think is
the worst dancer in uh worst dancer and
then who's the worst editor in vibrant
city
that's a good one that's a great one
there's no worst answer to you we'll
never get an answer we have some members
in kendra's that don't dance yeah so
then pick those [ __ ] yeah
that's the obvious answer
you have so many members you might as
well recruit a guy that's there just to
be named as the worst dancer cool
jojitsukawa hey
oh he's in kendra's now well i actually
danced congratulations
but he's not in kendra's for real though
you guys who why y'all being a bunch of
[ __ ] dude just [ __ ] saying yeah
hey that david be hard dude
yo what's the [ __ ] worst thing once i
[ __ ] extend my back like this
who's is there anybody that's currently
in uh probation like you might kick them
out and kendra's probation they're
recently [ __ ] up or something i'll
tell you tell me to cut off one of my
fingers i cut off the pinky that's how
simple it is which one's the worst
dancer first of all literally
[ __ ] last name it's not even apples
and oranges for you you know what i mean
are you talking about fruit sport
[Laughter]
yeah i'll do the middle finger oh okay i
mean because you could
how about your people off
inadvertently
that's the inverse between the lines
still didn't answer the question
it's not it's not we're talking you guys
don't even know i don't give a [ __ ] give
out give us a name dude
[ __ ] drama is it then
ooh no
who's been i don't know we watch
[ __ ] names this table wants names
they want names anthony is that ben tktk
chung
oh obtain b
he'll be like oh okay
it's probably chef rob
oh that's true this is specialty cooking
yes you guys have a chef on your team
yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing here dude
that's what we got over here welch's
[ __ ] fruit snacks maybe let's go we
have brown rice rollers dude come on
grab a [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go baby
that's for rich people
that's actually a chef that cooks for
you guys no he doesn't cook for us oh he
does cook for us from time to time
what's the point of having a chef in
your crew if they don't cook for you and
he doesn't dance useless what's his name
yeah why do you have already said his
name rob no what's his full name first
and last in address yeah yeah
and edges and asl wait the biggest thing
that stumped me was you guys have a
dance crew and you invite members of
part of your crew that don't dance we
have a crew
that dances
okay what's the point if you guys aren't
gang banging yeah each other
that's not far off yeah
what are we doing on a show called just
kidding news that doesn't report the
news hey hey
that's very [ __ ] good here's the real
news though who's that dancer that you
guys [ __ ] hate the most
squat
so bad david's not gonna let him slide
dancing off camera off camera
out of the dances out of the dancers out
of the dancers yeah it doesn't it
doesn't mean that they're bad it just
means that everybody's so dope somebody
has to go die yeah who's the one that
has to go die
it just got what this is the scenario
all right so
bart has a lot of guns
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then now you have to guys go into a
dance competition in space to battle
aliens like squid jam oh like squid
like squiggly so you have to go on to a
battle like a river runs through it
you're dance battling a bunch of aliens
right i don't know why bart has gone to
the situation but i just wanted to add
it because i'm going to use them okay
there you go
so now you want to eliminate i got this
gun
wow they have watch out that looks like
a [ __ ] assault rifle dude
they have 39 alien members 30 guys have
40. you have to get it
who's that one member you have to give
up this is to save the earth that's true
the leader of kid just needs to choose
that's why i'm on the b team right
no no no no no no no no no no no smart
place
who is the member that has to disappear
in order for you to save the earth you
have to one name
we'll go to hawk afterwards for his
answer yep
don't know all the dancers from you
would say charles wouldn't you charles
charles it is i i really just don't know
everything that's [ __ ] up charles is a
good dancer
that's so that's your answer
that's his answer i thought he would do
that let's go hawk yeah
no charles would say charles was stable
charles does a really good japanese
accent
i got a list of every name
love you nick just look at his face as i
name these out and you'll be able to
tell go go oh oh a hundred percent
almost
let's go
lauren's cow
now he's staying for sure he's too
talented he just booked something big
they need him for pr
oh we gotta keep him because he's the
tech guy that's true
you need him for the music we need him
for the like cody yeah that's like our
donald jason park
we could kill him yeah noah henderson
well he's killing more people than you
need to anthony well he's going on a
[ __ ] list i don't know what order
he's going yeah now we're uh jeff tang
who's a jeff tank that's not we don't
like who made this he just added himself
in there
is it that's website
from this is where are we really going
down a list of [ __ ]
foreign for sure oh my god that we're
doing this
arnelle calvario oh we got to kill him
he's too nice
let's go he's not going to fight for us
now you don't have any members to battle
you because you're short it was actually
a lot easier for you than you thought
yeah yeah yeah your doctor dog story is
a better story you know down to 17
members now
like you were supposed to come with 39.
we got six
quest
right
you